welcome to this video playing webmaster
Donald Draper never played it before
it's check has no name in there and
pretty pretty new account a case real
name is not Don Draper as I've seen a
bit of madmen okay we have got the
classical nims Oh Jack I'm going for
castles variation here um can I try
something else maybe maybe try this line
the gambit line with d5 it's a
surprisingly surprisingly good for black
I mean not liking like black is better
but it's very much a playable variation
if he takes Knight X gives black very
decent compensation yeah this is the
sound more popular muth just developing
and now I have some clear development I
DMB should be seven and so on d 697 hmm
maybe h6 first flick this in don't think
that taking and Quincy 7 stuff like that
is any good um I wonder do I play D 697
air do I put put a knight on c6 not
totally shown he might play a forward
some some moment
okay but that's not play too slowly him
I don't have any experience with the
line I only and you that that is quite
okay one of those main lines that simply
refused to go away for black it seems so
it seems okay um how do i play now if I
this was what I what I was afraid of
when I thought that maybe 96 could be an
idea so that I had before but now no
it's not possible to play before and the
problem be five is is slightly weak of
course yeah it's edged it always should
be should be a high queen bee force also
possible stinking queen bee three after
which I can advance but you can also go
to before yeah so that far hard too late
rook patm to protect us could even play
okay five then mm-hmm I don't know it
does not look very good maybe you really
need to play it differently that's
certainly not what black bonds when you
place this line d 6 is hanging now k
night 98a sir totally unplayable
proof
it's really a bad position really bad
yeah this is the solve I didn't see
anything could enciende else and this is
a simply simply terrible looking yeah
this was really an opening disaster okay
so taking here maybe I can go can get
something we can take the f three Pawn
maybe get 95 in
hmm he's just ignoring all of it andy
sixx is hanging as long okay what else
ok I will d to hangs but e5 as well take
care Queen chicks yeah not not much else
time morning Jim skiing side is very
slightly weakened very slightly 96 g5f
could be a counter plane but it's easy
to easy to a spot
maybe Queen f4 trying to get this
treated well if F 96 with the temple
next that's probably something that you
can wow really isn't this dangerous if I
get the Knight to g5 I could also have
taken
maybe I should have taken
listas would have been easier to play
rookie to
Quincy to made jack I don't I don't see
a win unfortunately look f 2 is there
some way to win Tia Carol's as the
problem is my time of course Knight f3
maybe another three check it does win
I didn't see that move at all check if I
didn't see that whether i thought i was
instantly winning of course i'm not
check
John I need to get rid of this this in
this pawn to get the hoops to get the
draw Jack
check
check game yeah ah what the heck yeah of
course I was totally lost so i don't
want mine to have drawn but of course he
gave me far too much in um the bottom i
say oh why did I think I could have
taken as a bishop on d3 okay well okay
this this was okay none and here yeah f3
in computer what does the computer want
to do just play look do you wanna add
very cold-blooded as usual I probably
don't have anything okay this this looks
very dangerous but this is this the
signals who they have no no win
amazingly check this is one truly
amazing point great really great so f
three years a bad move 95 is stronger
even okay went here I should win really
looking to look after yes yes I me Peter
chant here I do have a win a clear win
94 okay yeah I had 15 seconds the
problem was really that I thought I
didn't see king of two I thought he just
resigned here basically only saw this
move which is relatively easy check to
play for black even with this little
time i will pick up this pawn also so
this was really a bit shocking was glad
to try to get the Queen's off and it's
it's relatively easy to get the porn
in this little time I should have played
maybe each file immediately but is
difficult with with absolutely nothing
on the clock yeah i blundered blundered
this I wanted to play age 5 to fix the
pole and then take it check check yeah
okay I was doing okay at the end but I
guess I am made a mistake here in this
opening I think something like this is
pretty okay but maybe d 697 is wrong but
now maybe a maybe this is better
controlling important squares like
before so looks like a four there is
there's at least idea to play before
maybe sometimes two to go for set this
kind of structure maybe nights here when
when you went a four in the game yeah
maybe I should take but it's it's bad in
any case the problem is that here if he
takes why general this structure is very
weak a porn and I don't get my night to
be four and the other situation I have
the night on before at least for some
activity which is not the case here I
can play something like that but it's
not it's not doing that much I always
have this big pond I hear there's also
this to worry about I probably should
play 96 I'm not totally sure about the
opening ready yeah here I'm in terrible
shape and he probably can play play play
this much more convincing he took with
the rook I don't know I was even
thinking kingi to as I don't really see
what I do against it i mean a move like
that it's not not working yeah is
whatever is a very bad position out of
the opening okay thanks for watching
you